enen vente depuis deux semaines
àà Beloeil. Après une dizaine
dede visites, on attend toujours
unune première offre d'achat.
SASAMUEL MC DUFF,
cocourtier immobilier
- - Avec le COVID, c'était
vrvraiment la folie furieuse.
LLà, on sent que ça s'essoufle
lélégèrement, mais ça retombe un
pepetit peu comme à la normale.
CoComme avant le COVID, l'été,
c'c'est toujours un peu plus
trtranquille.
- - Les ventes de propriété ont
chchuté de 18 % dans le grand
MoMontréal en juilillet,
cocomparativement
àà l'an dernier, mais les prix
cocontinuent de grimper.
SuSur une période d'un an, c'est
unun bond de 10 % pour les maiss
ununifamiliales, de 9 % pour
leles copropriétés et de 15 %
popour les immeubles à logement.
LeLe rythme devrait toutefois
raralentir, selon ce courtier
hyhypothécaire.
HUHUGO LEROUX,
prprésident, Hypotheca
- - On pense, là, qu'on a vraimt
frfrappé le plateau des prix.
OnOn pense pas qu'on pourrait
prprésentement absorber d'autres
hahausses de prix pour
leles propriétés parce que
leles gens seront tout simplemet
papas capables de se payer
leles maisons.
- - La hausse des taux d'intérêt
etet de l'inflation semblent
avavoir refroidi les ardeurs
dede nombreux acheteurs.
LeLe nombre de propriétés sur
lele marché recommence à grimpe,
paparticulièrement dans
leles couronnes nord et sud dede
MoMontréal, ce qui n'avait pas
étété vu depuis quelques années.
L'L'impact se fera sentir.
CHCHARLES BRANT, Asso. profess.
dedes courtiers immobiliers du c
- - Les prix vont commencer
àà décroître, et c'est ce qu'on
obobserve depuis quelques mois.n
pepense qu'on a atteint le somm.
- - Un phénomène qu'on observe
dédéjà dans la grande région
dede Toronto, où les ventes ont
dédégringolé de 47 % en juillet,
etet le prix moyen des propriéts
a a baissé de près de 14 %
auau cours des six derniers moi.
LeLe marché, qui était nettement
fafavorable aux vendeurs,
cocommence à se rééquilibrer.
LALAURENCE JOLLIVET,
cocourtière immobilière
- - Il faut mettre au prix
dudu marché, ou voire en deçà
dudu prix du marché pour, non ps
avavoir des offres multiples,
mamais peut-être déjà avoir une
ofoffre, et pas nécessairement u
prprix que le vendeur voudrait.
- - C'est le même portrait
àà Vancouver, où les ventes ont
rereculé de 43 % en juillet
etet les prix de 5 %, au cours
dedes trois derniers mois.
GEGEORGES GAUCHER, directeur,
RoRoyal LePage Humania
- - On retourne tout simplementà
unun marché plus normal qui tenà
s's'équilibrer et il n'y a pas
lilieu de paniquer. On est loin
d'd'avoir perdu tout ce qu'on a
gagagné durant la pandémie.
- - Avec des prix qui fléchisset
dadans certains marchés,
etet une nouvelle hausse des tax
d'd'intérêt attendue cet automn,
dede nombreux acheteurs pourrait
memettre leur projetet d'acheter
unune maison sur pause, le temps
dede voir comment la situation
évévolue.
I Ici Olivier Bachand,
R Radio-Canada, Montréa